don't do the Steven Avery was this
innocent guy who how do you accidentally
throw a cat into a bonfire you ever been
there done that well you know I actually
I threw it over the fire okay how did
the gasoline get on the cat oh you know
I don't know they're down there by the
way these sounds they sound Gaelic okay
but my aunt lives up in Wisconsin they
don't sound like that this is a weird
bizarre family with a long history of
crime not only him his brother's violent
crime and likely inbreeding and that
family tree is a stump and none of this
is presented spoiler alerts huge spoiler
alerts for making a murderer on Netflix
okay I'm gonna give you five seconds not
good Jared you've watched this right you
know I you told me you're gonna ruin it
for me so I watched I binge watched
about eight eight nine hours of
yesterday okay so the spoilers are done
they just screw you don't you the
filmmaker I do you just what you're like
oh and you get screwed you really feel
screwed on this one because okay so
support everyone here spoiler alert if
you're still here write the whole thing
as an innocent man goes to to jail right
for a murder that they convinced you he
did not commit and from a corrupt police
force and so you're watching the whole
thing hoping there's redemption this guy
is the sweetest most innocent just sort
of unintelligent but like a pussycat
right or like a dog feel so bad for when
the cops are just hanging him out to dry
and then it just ends yep with him in
prison and you feel screwed and so I
watched it and I was really upset and I
understand first let me let me say this
yes it does shine a light on some
corruption in the judicial system yes
there are some bad police officers out
there yes there was some shady stuff
that happened in this trial and at the
very least seems like it should have
been ground grounds for a mistrial okay
yes Brendan Dassey should not have been
interrogated by himself because he is an
idiot and his lawyer I mean I don't know
if you can I don't know what the rule is
on suing a public defender for
malpractice but Mike terrible
all around okay but my problem here is
with incredibly dishonest filmmaking and
I know why this film came out at this
time it's come out at this time what the
black lives matter the whole movement
it's it's classism right see this is to
prove that poor people don't get access
to good good legal defense and if the
system fails them and that the cops have
all the power and how that's that's the
goal of this now they're like I've said
all those things I've conceded okay
there's some truth to that but well
there are two things firstly okay so you
can look at this and you can sign a
petition as everyone does to free
Stephen Avery and you can go cops are
corrupt and we need to change this and
this is exactly proof of black lives
matter and this is just like Mike Brown
and Ferguson and in Baltimore
and that's what this is it's a parallel
and if you see things when you watch
making a murder if you see things
through the prism of identity politics
right if you see black versus white rich
versus poor you're going to see the
narrative that you want but I see the
exact opposite okay and you can correct
me if you think that I'm wrong here
Jared I see the exact opposite because I
look at it through the prism of truth so
comparing Steven Avery let's assume he's
innocent for a second and all this was
corrupt but we'll get to that
comparing Steven Avery in the
prosecution to Darren Wilson and Mike
Brown what's the opposite right Steven
Avery was convicted in a court of public
opinion and so he couldn't get a fair
trial
absolutely true and that's just a
problem with modern technology
everyone's seen this these horrific
images and the news and you're condemned
before there's even a trial now who was
on trial with Darren Wilson wasn't Mike
Brown was Darren Wilson what happened
with officer Darren Wilson he was tried
in the court of public opinion hands up
don't shoot right we had people marching
with it was a lie it wasn't the truth
Darren Wilson may be a police officer
but again it's not about police versus
people it's not about rich versus poor
it's about truth Darren Wilson was
convicted by a jury of public opinion
until we found out actually yeah Mike
Brown did he was beating the hell out of
him and he was reaching for his gun and
that's where the altercation happened
and so he was set free so it's the
opposite in that case it's not police
corruption the real issue is the media
and people what I've learned
from this is simply wait for facts
before you making a decision oh the
jurors never had it's never such a
chance no I never said a chance there
was a chance so that's how I see it I
don't see it as a black lives matter
auntie police social justice Creed I see
it as we are in an era where people
don't really care about truth whether
it's looking for a convenient for a
conviction or a false defense so I think
that's important because I know what's
going to be used to push that and I
would be willing to bet that in a few
years time it's going to be like Michael
Moore when Michael Moore came out with
Roger and me everyone thought this guy
is this brilliant filmmaker shining a
light on truth then we find out he did
get an interview with with Roger head of
GM and he just edited out from the video
and now we know he's a partisan hack I
wouldn't be surprised if that happens
with these filmmakers 10 years down the
line we'll be going yeah they were great
when they did making a murderer no he
had no idea that they were part of
Greenpeace that kind of thing so that's
the first deal after watching it because
it was so screwed I thought there's got
to be more than this I felt manipulated
because anybody watching this would say
okay this is mistrial there's there's no
way but then I go well how does an
entire jury find him guilty and then how
are all of his motions for you know
appeals all of his post trial motions
nigh deny deny deny deny deny and why
did the judge go out of his way to
condemn him personally and why did
everyone in the town really hate in fear
they they've never really tapped into
any kind of motive questions for
anything either why he did the murder
they never really asked a motive like
why what kind of motive to be hat they
never really did I know what kind of
motive did the police department really
have other than the money that they
write owed him that was it right that
was it no motive so when I watched
Michael how is ever they must not be
seeing what I'm seeing so having said
all of that my problem is with dishonest
filmmaking and guess what there's a lot
that you missed on making a murder
Steven Avery is likely guilty doesn't
mean this wasn't wrong and it should be
mr. Utley this guy's prata this guy's a
murderer most likely who should go free
according to our legal system because of
tampering with evidence but a few things
so let me just kind of and one thing I
know some of these are sort of carrot
one thing I find the most telling the
most telling is that they talk about Ken
Kratz Ken Kratz the prosecuting attorney
yeah in the film they talk about him
having the sexting sexting scandal later
in the film it's really had nothing to
do with that it had enough
with anything what do they not mention
Steven Avery talked about creating a sex
torture chamber Brendan Dassey said he
was molested by Steven Avery these are
alleged Steven Avery doused a cat and
gasoline and burned it alive in a
bonfire family cat the family cat yeah
and you know for him he says that was
over that why because the filmmakers
were honest right they want to indict
the character of the cops and the
prosecuting attorneys but they want you
to sue Steven Avery's it's know he P he
dunked his cat and gasoline and threw it
in a bonfire okay this is proven the guy
did the live cat his live cat okay most
people would hear that right away and
want to watch this guy burn so that's my
problem as a dishonest filmmaker so that
happened what other past criminal
activity threatening a female relative
at gunpoint in the months leading up to
haul box disappearance Avery had called
Auto Trader several times specifically
asking for Teresa Halbach and she said
she was uncomfortable because he would
answer and make sexual advances
answering and only a towel the day that
Teresa Halbach disappeared he had called
three times twice from a twice from a
disguised number the bullet which you
don't see in the film the bullet with
her DNA on it had come from Avery's gun
which always hung above his mantelpiece
her blackberry her phone was found in
his burn bin the one thing that is
really damning to me that they don't
share with you is Brandon dasi right
absolutely should not have been
interrogated without his parents present
but what they don't show you there's a
21 page transcript is that he gave
information at that point that led to
more evidence discovery that they
couldn't have done without his testimony
like DNA under the latch of the hood non
blood DNA so it couldn't have come from
the vial and that was so that was
presented in the trial and end withheld
so there's a lot of other information
that was presented in the trial that was
withheld let alone all of this sort of I
guess you'd call it
auxiliary information so you watch it
and you think here's an innocent guy
who's a pussycat who couldn't hurt a fly
when he had hurt many people I mean
masturbating in front of his
his cousin or the sheriff's daughter I
think it was was something he did
committed crimes ran a relative or
friend of the sheriff's off the road
this is a guy who was causing problems
for a long long time we know he did time
for robbing a bar going in and stealing
their money
vandalism this is not an innocent none
of that is really shown it's skimmed
over so my issue is with manipulative
film making you'll have everyone going
out there probably signing a petition
there's lots of petition
yeah well this happen with Tookie
Williams right Tookie Williams killed
four different people in three different
incidents when he started the it was the
blood there's blood of the Crips and he
refused to ever testify against other
people who had killed people's sons and
daughters but he wrote a book a
children's book about avoiding gang
violence there was a girl it's time to
free him no it's not time to free me so
is there a lot of are there a lot of
things that went wrong yes and were the
cops corrupt absolutely and I think
there were problems what I think was
very likely and the reason every single
person was quick to convict and all of
his motions were denied is this was a
very violent sociopath with a long
history of criminal activity who had
hurt a lot of people and he likely did
the murder and the police wanted to
really make it stick and so they did
something they lied they did some things
that that's that's my opinion there are
other opinions circulating that's my
opinion what's not an opinion is this is
a violent criminal with a long history
regardless of this now does that mean a
wrongful conviction is right absolutely
not my point is don't drink all the
kool-aid don't do the hands up don't
shoot don't do the the the Mike Brown
was a 14 year old kid with a little baby
face right don't do the trayvon martin
was a kid who had never caused any
problems and wasn't getting high on
purple drank don't do the Steven Avery
was this innocent guy who how do you
accidentally throw a cat into a bonfire
you ever been there done that well you
say these it you know I actually I throw
it over the fire okay how did the
gasoline get on the cat oh you know I
don't know they're doing down here by
the way these you sound Gaelic okay I am
but my aunt lives up in Wisconsin they
don't sound like that this is a weird
bizarre family with a long history of
crime not only him his brother's violent
crime and likely inbreeding
and that family tree is a stump and none
of this is presented I'm not saying that
no the takeaway here social justice
warriors should absolutely be that we
should have a healthy fear of the state
because this is a state abusing its
power to go after someone who was likely
guilty but they could probably do it to
someone who's not so think about that
when you and Barack Obama as he's done
this week argues that the only people
who should have efficient weaponry are
police officers
everything about this special making a
murder if you watch it again if you see
it through the lens of class warfare and
identity politics you'll set the
narrative black versus white poor versus
rich cops versus everyone else if you
simply look at it through the prism of
truth what's the truth here you can't
see it as anything other than entirely
substantiating a conservative point of
view healthy fear of the state waiting
for facts and information before you
make a judgement and believing in the
judicial system or making sure that you
expose it when it's corrupt that is I
mean you say libertarian I guess
libertarian conservatives there's no way
to watch this and be a social justice
warrior black lives matter feminist
authoritarian so that was my that was my
point in not gey Jade you can tell me
what you think when you watched it i'ma
my off base but my blood was just
boiling no I don't think you are I think
you know I'm still I'm still processing
odd because I you know just binge
watched it yesterday but um by the way
we have Steven Avery calling us from
from you told me that this morning I
didn't break I didn't know about that
yeah um so you know that could be
interesting but uh yeah you know you I I
did you definitely feel very manipulated
watching all the way throughout that
that's kind of the agenda of the film
and I don't really know anything about
the filmmakers at all I mean other than
Netflix right I don't really know they
don't really come out and say who they
are and what their agenda is they just
kind of
you know feed you information as they as
they see fit but but did you kind of
feel that's the angle they were playing
oh yeah oh yeah and I mean to the credit
they did a really good job with did a
great job with it they I mean they kind
of went back and forth you kind of like
oh I think I think he's guilty I think
he's not you know through ten episodes
you you kind of toss and turn with it
until the end and you're like ah yeah
they kind of leave they leave you with
that sort of like an equal sign a
position we have to go to a break and
Steven Avery's going to be calling us
from prison that yep if people are
watching this they're terrestrially this
will be up online at la Torre's Crider
calm the phone call with Steven Avery
from prison it's an exclusive ladder
with Crowder's stay tuned hey if you
like this video subscribe by clicking my
face or this button or watch one of
these other videos if you're offended
you should leave